Today we had ordinarily
expected Paulo Zanoni,
who is a senior partner of
Goldman Sachs,
to be with us,
and it turns out we are a lower
priority than a new merger deal,
and we will have him a month
from today,
which gives us time to pull
together a bunch of important
details about the institutional
foundations of capitalism,
and I'm going to use the term
"wealth maximizing
law" today.
If you think about what courts
do,
and what legislators,
at any level from New Haven to
the Congress of the United
States,
they set rules which create
incentives and disincentives
that affect how people behave.
We're going to do four topics
today, but they're all ways of
talking about that.
I'm going to start with the
Coase Theorem,
which is not in your reading
packet, and neither is it,
strictly speaking,
a theorem.
But it is a foundational set of
concepts that Hernando de Soto's
book, which we are reading,
is built on.
De Soto has,
in effect, taken the Coase
Theorem, which is sixty years
back, and it won Ron Coase a
Nobel Prize about thirty years
ago;
has taken the Coase Theorem and
applied it to reality in a very
lively way.
The theorem is a good thing to
have in the background.
Second, and very briefly,
we're going to look at a law
case,
which is actually in the
syllabus for a little later in
term,
but I'm going to bring it
forward because this is really a
good place to show its result.
It's a case about whaling off
Cape Cod in the 1980s
[correction: 1880s].
And what's important about it
is not the facts of the case,
but the way the judge reasoned
his decision.
Third, we're going to do de
Soto in America,
which was the assignment in
this book for today's class,
and finally,
we're going to look at some of
the finer grained distinctions
in the way you can structure a
business organization.
Coase Theorem.
It's about this story,
this is a story we've all been
through, right?
About disputed ownership of
property.
Now I've noticed a pattern
here, and let's see if I've got
it right or not,
that you're always in that
third chair from the end of this
row,
and I think all three of you
are always in this orientation,
am I right?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay,
and how would it work out if,
let's say Leslie here,
came a little early next
Wednesday and sat in one of
those three chairs?
Student:  That would be
horrible.
Prof: It would be
Okay, now what would be
horrible about it?
You're all co-equally students
in the course;
the chairs, so far as I can
tell, are identical,
except that this one is broken.
What's up?
Student:  Well I'd that
this is sort of acknowledged as
my seat.
Prof: Okay,
it's acknowledged as your seat
and the other two of you would
say something very like that?
Student:
>
Prof: You own this one?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Okay.
What we have here is an
informal set of property rights.
There isn't a law of any kind
which refers to these rights,
but they are the folk way,
folk way norms of our
classroom.
Now if we press further,
let's take--do you live in your
college?
Student:  Do I what?
Professor Douglas W.
Rae:  In your college.
Student:  In my college?
Prof: Yeah.
Student:
>
Professor Douglas W.
Rae:  Do you live there?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Are there property
rights in and around your
entryway, and in your suite,
and so on?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Are they ones
written down by the Dean's
Office or by the Master?
Student:  I presume.
Prof: Are they?
Student:  I believe so.
Prof: Well,
I mean, aren't there some that
aren't written down?
Student:  Among our
students perhaps.
Prof: Well can you--I'm
trying to draw you out on this.
Student:  For example,
right here is a corner of the
common room, and dedicated to
his desk and his chairs,
studies.
Prof: Would you think of
sitting there?
Student:  No.
Prof: Okay.
Ray, how does it--does your
friend here have any rights or
not?
Student:  I guess I
would say no,
not where you go in.
Prof: I think we're not
doing that one this afternoon.
It's actually very suggestive,
right?
That there is--that beneath
government,
outside the actions of the
state, there is an enormously
intricate system of informal
property which governs the way
we actually function.
That system of property can be
good,
bad, or indifferent,
it can be just or unjust,
it can be notoriously
inefficient, and in fact,
if you think about the failure
of socialist regimes,
one important explanation is
that the underlying informal
norms about what people do with
their work lives were never
integrated with the planned
economies in an effective way.
Now--so that's something about
formality and informality.
I also have here a watch,
it says on the top Movado,
it's really very handsome and I
really don't need it.
I'm thinking of selling it.
Does anybody have any--does
anybody need a watch?
You do?
You don't?
What does a standard Movado
watch sell for in a jewelry
store?
I actually don't know.
I should have done my homework.
I think its low hundreds and
I'd be willing to part with this
one for $20.
Student:  Deal.
Prof: Who says deal?
Be careful.
Is it conceivable that the
proper retail price of this is
less than $20?
Student:  I think you're
a pretty trustworthy guy.
Prof: Remember what I'm
trying to demonstrate is
information asymmetry.
This watch is worth about $8,
and it's a--and if I sold it to
you what I would be doing is
stealing from the manufacturer,
stealing the brand.
One of the curious things about
watches these days--by the way,
it works fine.
Somebody gave it to me for my
birthday as a joke,
it keeps, as far as I can tell,
perfect time,
possibly better time than a
real Movado,
and there's an interesting
problem about watches,
right?
Which is better,
a $9 Casio, the cheapest
imaginable Casio or Timex;
or a Rolex, if the question is
keeping good time?
Student:  The Casio.
Prof: Pardon?
Student:  Probably the
Casio.
Prof: Yeah,
the Rolex is a mechanical
movement of brilliantly designed
and executed mechanical
movement,
and it's not as good as an
ordinary electronic watch;
doesn't keep time as well,
and yet people are willing to
pay thousand to one multiples
for the social meaning of the
brand.
That means that there's an
enormous market for cheaply made
watches,
gray market watches,
or even black market watches,
which knock off a brand name
and which people sometimes buy
really thinking that it's the
real deal,
but more often,
just thinking it's kind of fun
to buy an expensive brand for,
say, $20.
Well the Coase Theorem is about
those issues plus the one where
this girl is vexed.
And the one where she's vexed
is that the property rights to
that toy are unclearly marked.
I have a granddaughter who got
the boss gene from her mother
and she's a first--
kindergartner and her first day
at school they got out--
they brought out little plastic
ants for the children to learn
basic arithmetic with and they
put a pile of them on the--
in the middle of each table,
and than four kids.
And my granddaughter came home
complaining that the other kids
had been to her.
So her mother talked to the
teacher the next day,
and the story was that our
grandchild had taken all the
ants and put them in a pile and
then begun negotiating bilateral
agreements to give some to the
other students.
They didn't like that.
Well, the Coase Theorem boiled
down is that if you have three
conditions,
clear initial entitlements to
property and this is what's
stressed most in the de Soto
book;
clear entitlements to property;
a high degree of transparency,
which is what's missing in the
story about the bogus Movado
watch;
and low transaction costs.
The Nobel Prize in Economics,
announced today--
they announced two of them,
but one of them went to Ollie
Williamson,
formerly a colleague of ours
here at Yale,
for inventing and elaborating
the idea of transaction cost
economics.
By trans--have we talked a
little about transaction costs
here?
About how hard it is to do--to
get a deal made?
You know what deal you want to
make, but the--all the red tape
that gets in the way makes it
very difficult to get there.
Coase's principal point is that
in that tiny segment in the
middle of the Ven diagram,
where these three conditions
all obtain,
we should expect people to
reach efficient allocations of
property no matter what the
initial allocation.
Now notice I didn't say,
and he doesn't say,
fair or just allocations,
just efficient.
And efficient in the sense that
people will trade to a point
where there are no further
opportunities to--
for mutual gain,
and you get to a so called
Pareto efficient or contract
curve outcome.
And I'm going to--I don't do
this to you very often,
but we're going to do this with
a graphic demonstration.
This is an Edgeworth box.
I used one once before--does
anybody have any trouble about
how an Edgeworth box is set up?
Hum if you are.
Okay, so Smith is here,
Voltaire is there.
Smith gets that much paper and
that quantity of pens,
Voltaire gets the obverse
quantities.
If we start at the red dot,
Voltaire's entitlements are
shown by the blue lines and
Smith's by the pink lines.
Voltaire would prefer
anything--any outcome beyond
this indifference curve going
this way,
away from his point of origin,
and Smith would prefer anything
that way from the pink
indifference curve.
So there is a set of outcomes
which are clearly superior to
the starting point and they're
in that set, that lozenge in
shape.
And so they will trade to that,
and if we just set it up as
this is a rank order account of
what Smith wants and of what
Voltaire wants,
S is that set of outcomes and
those two--
S in the two diagrams is the
same thing.
Ultimately they'll get to an
outcome where the indifference
curves are at tangency to one
another;
there's no further gain from
trade,
and there will be a whole set
of outcomes that fit that
description,
forming the contract curve,
all those points,
and the contract curve will be
equivalent to this possibility
frontier in the other style of
diagram.
The--it's a really simple idea.
The way to use the Coase
Theorem though is backward.
The Coase Theorem is boring.
Incidentally,
I was talking to my TA's this
morning about the first round of
memos, and they had only one
complaint: that they were often
boring.
Not bad, but there was none of
the author's personality in most
of them.
You've all learned long since
how to write papers in college
and get good grades,
but you ought to just
occasionally put yourself into
it.
Don't do it the standard way,
just go out on a limb.
Now that's especially true if
you don't think you need to go
to law school,
med school or an MBA.
It's actually--I remember
making all the exact same
calculations when I was where
you are,
but a little risk taking in
writing actually endears you to
those who read the work,
and often actually pays off.
An interesting thing about
writing: After your B.A.,
taking risks with your writing
turns out to be the only way of
getting ahead.
Standard issue writing pays up
to the B.A., and by and large
doesn't pay after.
It's interesting.
At any rate,
I don't mean to alarm you about
your grades, but I think it's
actually worth thinking about.
I've mislabeled this.
The top label should read
Ghen v.
Rich, and this is a case
about thinking out the
incentives to make people behave
in productive ways.
The story goes as follows:
Ghen is a whaler;
he operates out of Wellfleet,
Massachusetts.
It is 1881 and he spots a
finback whale and sends the
little boats out with his crew
and they harpoon the whale.
Finbacks are big,
fast, aggressive,
and they have one further
peculiarity, when you kill them
they sink to the bottom of the
sea.
Virtually all whales float when
killed and the general rule of
property in whaling is finder's
keepers, loser's weepers.
You've all heard of that.
The specific method is that
after you kill a whale you
either lash it to your ship and
tow it to harbor,
or slice it up and process it
at sea,
but these boats by and large
weren't big enough for that.
Or you leave it floating and
put a marker on it,
and the marker is your--it's
your brand.
It's like branding cattle,
and everybody then is compelled
by law to acknowledge that it's
your whale.
The finback presents a dilemma
because neither of those
strategies is available to the
whaler who kills a finback.
What happened to this
particular finback is that it
floated up a day or two later on
the beach near Wellfleet on Cape
Cod.
And a gentleman came along and
found it, and conducted a quick
auction, and Ellis bought it.
Ellis bought the whale and
processed it into whale oil and
other by products,
put them on the market and at
this point,
Ghen returned from his voyage
and wanted his whale back.
He sued Ellis--Rich,
rather, sorry;
Ellis is the guy on the beach
who found it.
He sued Rich,
who had processed the oil for
his money.
What happened was that the
judge ruled in favor of Ghen and
reasoned--well,
let me not tell the whole
story.
Let's suppose you were hired as
attorney for the finback whales.
The finback whales hire you as
a lawyer and they want to get
this case to come out so that
they will be safe from whaling
in the future.
How would they have the judge
decide the case?
Back--
Student:  Decide in
favor of Rich
>
Prof: Okay,
exactly, and why?
Student:  Because the
whalers were taking all the risk
and all the time,
but they were not going to be
able to bring the whale in.
And Rich gets all the--or
whoever finds the whale's body
two days later gets all the
profit, why harpoon them?
It's completely
>
Prof: Okay, perfect.
The judge reasoned,
just as suggested,
that only by honoring the
relatively indirect claim to
property,
which Ghen was urging,
could the industry of whaling
for whalebacks be incented so
that it would go on in the
future.
Now a lot of things we're doing
and thinking about are analogous
to that.
Structuring incentives so that
people behave in ways which
increase the wealth of society
while trying to increase their
own wealth in effect creating
conditions analogous to the
invisible hand in Smith is what
the judge was doing.
It's actually--you should
Google it, it's only three pages
long, and just read the opinion.
Because it brings out the
fundamental issues that we're
trying to deal with.
Now de Soto in America.
De Soto talks in the early
parts of the book which we read
at the opening of term.
De Soto talks mainly about
emerging market countries.
The gist is that they are
loaded with dead capital.
Can somebody help us with the
notion of dead capital?
Here we go.
Student:  De Soto argues
that why capital serves both as
purpose as a house and kind of
second like is to serve to
backing of future investments.
Like in a country where you
have a legal right over your
house, it can't serve the second
purpose.
Prof: Okay so the
house--let's take the chair you
own here.
Is it dead capital or live
capital?
Student:  Well it's not
alive to me because I don't own
it but to the university maybe
it's alive.
Prof: Okay,
that's well put.
We will in fact look at the
title to this room in a few
minutes.
The--de Soto's idea is that in
an informal system of property
which has not been integrated
with a governmental system of
property,
people have capital,
but it is dead in the sense
that it can't be used for
collateral against a loan,
and if it is sold,
there is no way to enforce the
contract on the sale except
mafia style,
and mafia style often doesn't
work out all that well.
The chapter we read for today
is about the proposition that
the advanced economies didn't
get to having live capital all
at once.
It came through a long process,
and de Soto,
in this chapter,
talks through the informal
practices of property which grew
up in mining camps in
California,
in agricultural communities in
Iowa and other Midwestern
states,
in claims to land in colonial
America.
What I'd like to do is start at
the present and then work our
way back.
This is a property map of our
present neighborhood.
This is an official government
map from the place where deeds
are kept at 200 Orange Street in
New Haven and in every community
in the United States you will
find a set of deeds and a
corresponding set of maps
similar to this one.
I'll dissect this and enlarge
parts of it and so on as we go.
You'll find these maps are
quite ubiquitous.
Now this one has the
peculiarity that in some parts
of the city they've drawn in the
buildings and it turns out that
that's--
that has happened where there
is a wealthy institution that
paid to have it done,
familiar to all of us and not
where there isn't a wealthy
institution that would pay to
have it done.
The green lines represent
property parcels and all this is
entirely accessible if you go--
if you Google Visionappraisal,
one word,
Visionappraisal New Haven,
you'll get all these files and
you'll get a photograph of every
structure to go with it.
Here we have a particular
parcel that includes and
surrounds this building.
There's a close up of the
building and we're in the--you
can see the match there.
Let's look at three properties
first and then we'll look at
some more and we'll see how
structures of ownership get
built around the formalized
property parcels;
61 High Street is this building.
Anybody know what 64 High
Street is?
No idea?
What's the small stone--small
brownstone building across the
way?
Student:  Skull and
bones.
Prof: Skull and bones,
and skull and bones turns out
for property purposes to be
called The Russell Trust and
we'll look at that,
and 41 High Street?
I was just there,
is Starbuck's and some other
property above it.
Let's look at--well I--1066
Chapel is actually Starbuck's,
I was mistaken in what I said a
minute ago,
41 High is the building right
behind Starbuck's.
This is what you find on the
land records.
This building is Parcel 14188,
map 261, block 252.
It has an effective total area,
and this means places you could
do anything with,
and this would count every
square foot of indoor or outdoor
space,
and it totals a little over
100,000,
of which 9,259 is heated indoor
space.
Its asserted value from the
city is $2.68 million for the
land,
$4.97 million for the building,
$7.65 million all together and
of that $7.65 million,
$7.65 million is exempt from
taxes in the city,
and that's a point of interest
to the city.
What I'm trying to get you to
do is just get into the details
of this stuff and see how
interesting it is.
The net value to the city for
tax purposes is zero,
owner Yale University.
Now compare this to 1066 Chapel
where the numbers are smaller
because the buildings are
smaller and they're nowhere near
as good.
The net taxable value is
$500,000.
The owner is something called
Chapel Investments,
LLC.
LLC is owned by people I know,
the Warrick family,
and they own four parcels over
there,
including the one in which
Caesar Pelli has his
architectural office and so on,
and it is organized as a
taxable corp--
a taxable LLC which is--this is
a hybrid form which we'll get to
at the end of the hour.
Now let's take the value of
this building and the way it
looks to Yale and the city.
If we wanted to mark-to-market
Lindsey Chittenden Hall,
we want to say,
"What would this building
really sell for?
This building and the land in
question."
How would we go about that?
Who's got an estimate?
More or less than $7.65 million
dollars?
More, who said more?
Okay there we go.
Why do you think so?
(32:55--starts to get
choppy--audio is fine).
Student:  It's a
building that has a lot of
history and a lot of alumni
might be interested in it.
It has beautiful artwork,
nice carving,
you know, you could put a pool
in.
Prof: Okay,
does it look like it's well
maintained?
Student:  Yeah,
very well maintained.
Prof: Might buying this
have any resemblance to buying a
Movado watch of this
description?
Let's suppose I want to run
a--some kind of a commercial
educational institution,
what would this building be
worth if I were--
suppose I were going to run
something which was aimed at
wealthy kids with bad test
scores.
Student:  It would be
nice to be associated with the
Yale brand.
Prof: Yeah I might name
it Rae College at Yale.
That has a ring to it, right?
The building--use that--that
might be the highest and best
use of the building.
Anybody else got a thought
about what--yes,
Tom is it?
Student:  You're going
to have to start paying taxes on
it?
Prof: I am.
Well, unless I can get it made
into a 501(c)(3),
nonprofit corporation,
in which case I might get away
with not paying taxes.
Any other use anybody can
imagine for this thing?
Come on--yes.
Student:  I would
actually argue that property
value would be lower because the
building is
>
that in some ways it's unlikely
to find anybody who would value
it as much as this
>
Prof: Well I--can we
think of anything unrelated to
education you could do with
this?
Could it be a resort?
Student:  I'd make it a
movie theatre.
Prof: Pardon.
Student:  I'd make it a
movie theatre.
Prof: You would make it
a movie theatre.
Well I got to tell you I think
that's a really bad idea.
If you study the current
economics of movie theatres,
don't do it.
Anybody else?
Student:  You don't have
to look at the alternatives,
you can look at how much Yale
invested in renovating this
building as an indication of how
much Yale values it and so if
Yale didn't own it it would be
able to--
it would be willing to pay a
tremendous amount of money,
I think, to buy it and that
would give it a lot of value.
Prof: Well,
that's right and that,
by the way, is a good reason to
think that they're not going to
sell it for any price that we
could even imagine capturing the
value from.
I think that's right.
Now, the other property is
probably already--
the Starbuck's one is probably
already pretty much at highest
and best use and is therefore
uninteresting.
Now let's think about the
properties on the other end of
the block across Chapel Street,
the end down toward the New
Haven green.
There's a large assembly,
there are about fifteen parcels
down there.
I picked out three.
They all look like this.
They all belong to something
called The Chapel Company.
Who can make a guess what The
Chapel Company might be?
Well I'll tell you--yes?
Student:  I was going to
say possibly Yale.
Prof: How perceptive.
Here's the story:
Twenty-five years ago,
a Yale college alum named Joel
Schiavone, who is an irascible
and brilliant fellow.
He has the same educational
pattern as Jim Alexander here,
Yale College,
and Harvard Business School.
He bought--it was a slum,
all these--this whole area down
here was a commercial slum.
The buildings were in
disrepair, they were being used
for very marginal purposes,
and he bought the whole thing
up for not very much and began
renovating it.
The renovation model was small
retail.
Small retail with quality
residential on the second and
third floors and we're talking
about places like The Union
League and Claire's Cornercopia,
and The Schubert Theatre and
The Taft Hotel now The Taft
Condominium.
He fixed it all up and made it
really sing and one of his
precepts was every property
should be leased to somebody who
owns their own business and is
willing to work really hard at
making it work.
He didn't go after chains he
went after entrepreneurs.
The thing really worked
beautifully but Schiavone is one
these guys who--he's got the
spirit of Schumpeter about him.
He can never leave well enough
alone.
He gets interested in other
things and leverages the new
things by taking further
mortgages on all this property.
Then in the 1980s there is a
huge real estate recession,
and he loses it all to a
federal--the federal government
buys all the property for very
little and then auctions it off
for something called the RTC,
and Yale hires a guy named Joe
Fahey who was a student of mine
at SOM at the time this
happened.
He now runs all of Disney's
real estate,
and Fahey invented The Chapel
Company and bought all of
Schiavone's property on Yale's
behalf for about $.25 on the
dollar.
Yale has had the good judgment,
in my opinion,
to leave it all functioning as
if it were private commercial
property,
and the neighborhood is
strengthened enormously by that
and Yale does not make a lot of
money at it,
but it indirectly gets a lot of
benefit by having a strong
commercial neighborhood abutting
the campus.
We're not quite ready for that.
Well let's not use the maps but
let's do--let's talk about
properties further up in the
middle of campus.
I'd like you to focus on 140
High Street and 306 York Street.
140 High Street is the Yale Law
School ,and its taxable value is
$42 million dollars,
that's the building not the
institution.
Across York Street is Mory's,
or more exactly,
The Mory's Trust.
What do you think Mory's is
worth?
Well the tax estimate is
$400,000 and a little bit.
Who would be prepared to buy
Mory's for $400,000?
No takers?
Anybody tempted?
Okay, why are we so cautious
about Mory's?
Student:
>
Prof: Pardon?
Student:  Why are we
what?
Prof: Why are cautious
about Mory's?
Student:  Well,
because it's failing right now.
Prof: It closed its
doors on December 19 last year,
what's wrong with that?
Student:  It would make
me skeptical about the area,
like maybe there's something
wrong with the business around
it,
or what's around it would make
it less valuable as a commercial
space.
Prof: Okay,
yeah, it's sure a rundown
neighborhood.
You've got the Yale Hall of
Graduate Studies,
Morrison, Stiles.
Student:  No,
I mean as opposed to the Chapel
area where there's a whole area
that is like a commercial area,
and maybe sort of out of place.
I would consider buying it
personally because I think it
could be used effectively
Prof: I am the chairman
of the group that in fact owns
it.
I'm going to try not to take
offense at the way you guys
value it.
We're investing $3 million
dollars in it over the next four
months and we plan to open it
and have all of you clamoring to
get through the front door,
or the backdoor,
which will be the Whiffenpoof
Bar.
Now in evaluating it you do
have to take into account lots
of things that aren't bricks and
mortar, and I'm glad you said
what you said.
You're blaming the neighborhood
for what is in fact a
spectacularly mismanaged
business.
Did anybody eat in Mory's last
year?
Can you--can we get the
microphone to this lady,
we're going to a--on a one to
five star basis,
what's the rating?
Student:  You mean,
compared to dining hall food
or--
Prof: Compared to food
that costs about the same thing
on the private market.
Student:  I mean,
I was never paying but--I mean
a three.
Prof: A three?
Student:  The food's not
that good but it's really fun.
Student:  I'd say a one.
Prof: Okay the fun part
was the singing,
the memorabilia,
the cockroaches .
no, I'm kidding but the food
was notorious.
It was really bad.
How well did they do at serving
drinks?
Student:  Very well.
Prof: I mean, horrible.
There was no bar,
the tables down at Maury's had
no bar, and it failed partly
because it was very badly
managed.
It was managed by fifteen Yale
alumni, not one of whom knew
anything about business.
That's a little harsh.
Not one of whom knew anything
about business except for being
a stockbroker,
which is a pretty abstract
business.
There are no cooks in a
brokerage house.
The other side of it,
and we'll actually do this case
before we're done.
The other side of it was a
highly restrictive labor union
contract with Local 217,
here and that contract doesn't
go away when you close the door.
It turns out under Connecticut
labor law that the contract,
if you reopen a restaurant
there, you would normally expect
you would have to honor the
contract.
Now it turns out we have a
loophole that's going to get us
more--a better deal than that.
I'll give you an idea of what
the--so what that means is that
given the labor law the value of
the building is affected by the
existence of the union contract.
It becomes almost like paint in
the way it adheres to the thing.
It included,
for example,
the provision that there should
be four people called cashiers
who count the cash each night;
only one on duty each night,
they rotated.
They were all part timers.
One of them was s full time
teacher at a local high school,
and they were required that
you--we were required to pay
them four hours for each
appearance and each appearance
was--
how much cash do you think you
take in these days in a
restaurant of that kind?
None;
there might on a good night be
$100 to count but the contract
obliged Mory's to employ these
guys, and worse yet,
to pay them vacation time.
We have a high school teacher
being paid five days of vacation
time by Mory's while he is on
vacation, paid vacation,
from The Branford School
System.
That's a deal.
Analyzing what gets built on
this framework is a little
complex.
Let's go through the big story
in de Soto about the informal
property systems in the United
States.
Can anybody summarize it for us
in 100 words?
Got a taker out there?
Are you headed for a taker?
Okay I'll do it.
The system of property is built
on nation states.
Nation states are the
underlying unit.
When you have a frontier
society, which the United States
remained until about 1880,
you have a vast area where
there is effectively no state or
if there is a state it is a very
weak state with very limited
capacities to enforce any
property system.
The key Green v.
Bittle case,
which arose in Kentucky,
asserted the following.
It said informal property
rights count for nothing,
only formal property rights
issued by a part of the United
States Government,
at either the federal or the
state level,
count as real.
This provoked a rebellion that
included violence.
It also created an enormous
inefficiency because the
existing informal system of
property rights based on
preemption and occupation,
so called Tomahawk rights or
cornfield rights;
you occupy the land,
improve the land,
demonstrate that you're making
a living from the land,
and it becomes yours.
Homesteading was the name for
it.
In 1862, The Homestead Act,
adopted into Federal law that
system of informal law and made
an integration between the two
levels.
The wealth that was built in
the United States in the--
in everything outside the
original East Coast colonies is
built up on that peace treaty
between formal and informal.
The--he does a brilliant job,
de Soto does,
with the mining camps in
California and with the land
claim associations in the
Midwest,
and you can read the details
for yourselves.
The gist is that a well
functioning system of property
will have both the formal and
the informal rights in sync with
one another,
not in tension with one another.
If we go finally to the finer
details of business
structure--we're done now.
I'll use this at the beginning
of class on Wednesday.
I'll talk about how Mory's is
being restructured and you
should--
the case as scheduled for
Wednesday is the one about the
mortgage meltdown in Cleveland,
Ohio and the URL has been
posted on Classes V2.